صواريخ الساعه صفر هكذا باتت هذه الدفعه
الصاروخيه الاكثر شهره في الحرب الحاليه
تطلق كتائب القسام دفعه صاروخيه كبيره من
قطاع غزه باتجاه وسط
اسرائيل جاءت بعد ساعات فقط من ترويج
الاعلام الاسرائيلي الى ان اسرائيل
ستستقبل العام الجديد وقد انخفضت القوه
الصاروخيه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه بشكل ملحوظ
لكن اسرائيل قبلت العام الجديد بدفعه
صاروخيه من قطاع
غزه دفعه تحمل كثيرا من الرسائل العسكريه
والسياسيه تقول كتائب القسام من هذه
الدفعه انها لا تزال قادره على القياده
والسيطره تطلق دفعه صاروخيه في وقت واحد
هو الساعه الصفر في العام
2024 واستهدفت مكانا واحدا هو تل ابيب
تشير هذه الدفعه كذلك الى ان القسامه
قادره على التحكم فيما يعرف عسكريا
باقتصاد القوه اي ان الكتائب تختار الزمان
والكميه المناسبه التي تريد ان تضرب بها
هذا يعطيها طابعا من السيطره المحكومه
بالهدوء المؤدي الى التحكم في مسار
المعركه اذ ان صواريخها ليست مجرد رد فعل
على القصف الاسرائيلي بل اداه لاداره
المعركه وفق ما تراه المقاومه مناسبا
اللافت للنظر ان القسام نشرت فيديو يوثق
عمليه الاطلاق بعد 28 دقيقه فقط من
التنفيذ 28 دقيقه فقط كانت كافيه للتصوير
والعوده الى غرف المونتاج وتحميل المواد
الفيلميه واختيار المقاطع المطلوبه ورفعها
على الانترنت هذا يعني ان كتائب القسام لا
تزال قادره ايضا على اداره المشهد
الاعلامي العسكري بطريقه تؤدي الغرض
المطلوب اما في الرسائل السياسيه فقد كانت
الدفعه الصاروخ من طراز ام 90 قبل ساعات
من اطلاق صواريخ الساعه الصفر نشرت
الكتائب ماده تعريفيه بمنظومتها الصاروخيه
تشمل هذه المنظومه ثماني عائلات من
الصواريخ المتنوعه تحتوي كل عائله على
صاروخ الى خمسه صواريخ وكل واحد منها معرف
باسم ومدى كان صاروخ ام 90 جزءا من عائله
صواريخ المقادمه الذي دخل الخدمه عام
2022 تنسب هذه العائله الصاروخ
الى الشهيد ابراهيم المقادمه احد قاده
ومؤسسي حركه حماس وجناحها العسكري الذي
اغتالته اسرائيل بقصف صاروخي ابانا
انتفاضه الثانيه قبل 20 عاما ثمت صواريخ
ضمن عائلات اخرى في منظومه القسام يصل
مداها الى قرابه ثلاثه اضعاف المدى الذي
يصله
[موسيقى]
المقادمه لكن الكتائب اختارت ان يعود
ابراهيم المقادمه الى اسرائيل على صاروخ
في الساعه صفر من العام